>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
WE ARE HERE IN MINNEAPOLIS,
WHERE THE DEREK CHAUVIN JURY
WILL HOLD ITS FIRST FULL DAY OF
DELIBERATIONS TODAY.
THIS CASE AND OTHERS HAVE
BROUGHT A NEW FOCUS ON POLICE
TRAINING AND TACTICS ALL ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY.
NOW, LAWMAKERS IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON ARE TRYING TO CHANGE
THE WAY OFFICERS DO THEIR JOBS
THERE.
AS KRIS VAN CLEAVE REPORTS, IT
ALL STARTS WITH A NEW APPROACH
TO TRAINING.
>> WE'VE GOT RESOURCES, MY
FRIEND.
>> Reporter: OLYMPIA,
WASHINGTON, POLICE OFFICER
JAVIER SOLA IS IN A NEW KIND OF
TRAINING EVEN A DECADE ON THE
JOB.
THE FORMER MARINE IS PRACTICING
DE-ESCALATION TECHNIQUES AIMED
AT SHOWING NEW RECRUITS AND
OFFICERS SOMETIMES THE TWO STEPS
FORWARD CAN TAKE TWO STEPS BACK.
>> WE SLOW DOWN THE PACE, THAT
WILL INCREASE THE OPTIONS.
I BELIEVE IF WE INCREASE THE
OPTIONS, THAT WILL DECREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF EITHER PARTY
GETTING HURT.
>> Reporter: AND NOW THE
WASHINGTON STATE TRAINING
COMMISSION IS INCORPORATING
ACTIVE BYSTANDER TRAINING IN
THIS CLASS AND THROUGHOUT ITS
CURRICULUM.
IT'S ONE OF THE FIRST IN THE
COUNTRY TO REQUIRE IT FOR ALL
NEW RECRUITS.
CJTC TEACHES OFFICERS TO TAKE
ACTION IF THEY SEE A COLLEAGUE
VIOLATING POLICY OR EXCUSING
EXCESSIVE FORCE WITH THE GOAL OF
AVOIDING THE SITUATION LIKE THE
GEORGE FLOYD CASE.
>> WHOA, HOLD ON.
>> Reporter: OR THIS TRAFFIC
STOP IN VIRGINIA LAST DECEMBER
INVOLVING AN ARMY LIEUTENANT.
DOZENS OF AGENCIES NATIONWIDE
ARE NOW FOLLOWING WASHINGTON'S
LEAD.
>> REALLY JUST EMPOWERING
OFFICERS TO STEP UP AND
INTERVENE.
AND KEEP IMPROVING ON THE
TRAINING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ROLL OUT.
THE DE-ESCALATION TRAINING.
THAT'S THE BEGINNING OF HOW YOU
START TO BUILD TRUST BUT IT'S A
SLOW PROCESS.
>> Reporter: SEAN HENDERSON
TRAINS POLICE OFFICERS ACROSS
THE STATE.
>> IT'S REALLY ABOUT NOT GETTING
YOURSELF SO DEEP INTO THESE
EVENT WHERE IS TIME STARTS
SPEEDING UP AND YOU'RE FORCED TO
MAKE THESE DECISIONS FASTER THAN
YOU SHOULD BE MAKING THEM.
STOP!
>> Reporter: LAST MARCH, EMANUEL
MARCH DIED.
13 MONTHS LATER, THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING THE REPORTS.
VI
VIDEOS.
>> THAT TRAINING SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE.
>> Reporter: ELLIS' SISTER
MONET.
>> I KNOW I WILL NOT MURDER
PEOPLE BECAUSE I COULD GO TO
PRISON FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
THEY NEED RULES FOR OFFICERS
JUST LIKE WE NEED RULES IN
PLACE.
>> Reporter: A DOZEN BILLS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE WASHINGTON STATE
LEGISLATURE, AIMED AT INCREASING
ACCOUNTABILITY, BANNING TACTICS
LIKE CHOKE HOLDS AND REQUIRING
BYSTANDER TRAINING FOR ALL
OFFICERS, ADDING DISCIPLINARY
ACTION IF THEY DON'T STEP IN AND
REPORT BAD CONDUCT.
MANY OF THESE REFORMS ARE
STALLED IN CONGRESS.
>> THERE'S AN IMPETUS TO GET
THIS DONE.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATIC STATE
SENATOR MAN-KA DHINGRA.
>> THEY NEED THE RULES.
>> Reporter: BUT THE OFFICERS
WORRY THE REFORMS WILL DRIVE
PEOPLE AWAY FROM A CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> THIS SWEEPING REFORM IS GOING
TO HAVE AN AFFECT, REALLY AN
IMPACT, ON RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION IN THE PROFESSION.
AND ALSO PUBLIC SAFETY IN
GENERAL.
>> IT DOESN'T TAKE A LOT OF BAD
POLICING TO MAKE THE WHOLE
PROFESSION LOOK BAD.
>> Reporter: AFTER BECOMING THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN CAPTAIN IN THE
PATROL, MONICA ALEXANDER NOW
OVERSEES TRAINING.
IN THE CTC.
>> IT'S FROM THE TOP DOWN.
IF WE'RE SERVANTS HOW DO YOU
SERVE YOUR PEOPLE?
WITH HUMILITY, WITH KINDNESS AND
GAINING THEIR TRUST.
>> Reporter: I THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WOULD SAY THAT POLICE
AREN'T DOING THAT, THAT POLICING
IS BROKEN.
> I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
SAY THAT.
THERE ARE PARTS THAT ARE BROKEN,
RIGHT?
THE WHOLE CAR ISN'T DISABLED.
IT'S JUST PARTS.
AND WE HAVE TO FIX THOSE PARTS.
>> Reporter: EIGHT OF THOSE
POLICE REFORM BILLS HAVE NOW
PASSED THE WASHINGTON STATE
LEGISLATURE.
ONE HAS BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW.
FOUR OTHERS ARE STILL PENDING.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE USE
OF FORCE AROUND MANUEL ELLIS'
DEATH COULD WRAP UP AS EARLY AS
THE END OF THE MONTH, GAYLE.
>> CKRIS, WHAT A GREAT ANALOGY,
WHERE SHE SAID THE WHOLE CAR IS
NOT DISABLED WE JUST HAVE TO FIX
THE PARTS.
BUT I LOVE THAT ANALOGY.
I HAVE A QUESTION, WE KNOW THAT
THE HOUSE PASSED A BILL THAT
BEARS GEORGE FLOYD'S NAME.
DO YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
PROGRESS ON THAT LEGISLATION?
>> Reporter: GAYLE, THE BILL
REMAINED STALLED IN THE SENATE
BUT IN THE DAYS SINCE THE
SHOOTING OF DAUNTE WRIGHT, THERE
IS INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS BEING
HAD BETWEEN REPUBLICAN STORIES
AND DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE ABOUT